let's go back to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero four seven five
zero and let's go to our caller from the
nine seven three area code who's calling
today from 973 hello yes that's you and
please keep the phone a little further
from your mouth you you're just coming
in so loud this better
that's much better thank you okay hi I'm
remember I called last I called a couple
weeks ago but then the phone cuz the
phones aren't crashed and I never really
and you know I never got an answer to my
question okay the question was asked
before I was curious as to like why you
know hypothetical scenario as to why
Bernie who did well in Michigan in 2016
for example lost Michigan horrendously
in 2020 and I said a theory was one that
George Orwell had just described in his
book the road to work in fear where he
said that although everyone ought to be
a socialist the reason why working-class
people turn away from socialism is
because it attracts it attracts when he
described Craig's you know people who
like we described them as like you know
sandal wearing tweed you know that you
can't really describe them there's like
vegetarian nudists feminists in his own
words and I kind of wonder do you think
that like in 2020 the progressive
movement ignored oil that what Orwell's
warnings in the book and paid the
consequences of it I'm not familiar with
that Orwell quote but listen if you look
at any of my post mortems on what
happened to Bernie there is no question
that the language of revolution the not
simply saying hey listen guys I'm a
social democrat not a democratic
socialist social democracy is a
regulated form of capitalism I don't
think that the democratic socialist
label helped I think some of the people
around him didn't help so yeah I mean I
I it in I essentially completely agree
with what you're quoting to me from
George Orwell and every post mortem I've
done of why Bernie lost and lost badly I
mean I know people say you know
you can't look at the vote totals now
because Bernie dropped out a little
while ago Biden was up by almost two
million votes while Bernie was still
fully running the campaign it was not a
small victory for Biden and I think all
the things you're alluding to via the
george orwell quote are a hundred
percent in line with my analysis I'm
also curious what your thoughts are on
this failed invasion of Venezuela since
I didn't hear anything of it unless you
mentioned it on the bonus show I don't
know much about it I I know that there
were some I don't even know what to call
the mercenaries I guess they would be
called and there were allegations that
they were associated somehow with the
Trump administration although every
every source for that was was sort of
different versions of propaganda state
media that were saying that so I don't
I'm still researching that I've not
taken a position one way or the other on
it I mean obviously I'm against any coup
in Venezuela that the u.s. is involved
in to just get that on the record what I
mean is I don't know enough about that
situation to comment intelligently right
now okay okay
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call great to hear from you